altered
i could smell the storm in your blood
your stink of enoch
so what i should play at being a god
like you
i am not playing
[Music]
outriders a co-op rpg shooter set in a
dark
original sci-fi universe
created by people can fly previously
part of the epic games group
the studio is renowned for developing
world-class shooters
like bullet storm and the gears of war
[Music]
series
humankind is bleeding out in the
trenches of enoch
a once beautiful planet ravaged by a
mysterious anomaly
[Music]
hyper-evolving its flora and fauna to
purge the virus that
is humanity
in other words you
now enoch is hell off earth
[Applause]
leading the colonization advance party
the outriders are devastated by an early
storm
while most of the unit is wiped out you
not only survive
but are left altered something more than
human
now with control over time space
and matter the outriders have gained
access to devastating anomaly energies
demigods strolling through the
battlefield the tables have most
definitely turned
with the anomaly flowing through their
veins outriders have split off into four
classes
each offering a different customizable
play style and extensive skill tree
that while freely respectable demands
hard choices be made
if you prefer a devious hit and run
approach the trickster's manipulation of
time and space will be to your tastes
deadly up close the trickster will
annihilate enemies with spectacular
powers
such as the temporal slice
or if death from a distance is more your
thing the technomancer combines the
anomalies powers
with technology place deadly turrets or
release
climate-altering area effect weapons to
take down your foe
the devastator class is a tank in human
form
a biological sledgehammer difficult to
kill
and dangerous to be near the
devastator's control of gravity
allows for brutal attacks such as the
impale ability
or gravity jump
[Music]
finally there's the pyromancer a
medium-range class equipped to take out
multiple targets at once
you may be easy to kill at close range
but you can leech energy from crowds of
enemies or
detonate thermal bombs to tear their
flesh apart
regardless of your choice confidence is
everything on the battlegrounds of enoch
each class has its own spin on a healing
mechanic
which rewards health for performing
certain actions that reinforce the
classes play style
so get out of cover throw yourself head
first into the fray
and think aggressive the outriders
journey will take them beyond humanity's
furthest exploration of enoch
as they fight to discover the source of
a mysterious signal
from the snow-capped heights of eagle
peaks to dense jungles and arid deserts
deadly enemies that have adapted to
their environment to wait
there's plenty to discover off the
beaten path too outriders is rich with
side quests and additional story you may
be pulled into a search and rescue
mission
drawn in to investigate a menacing cult
or
ask to track and kill hyper-evolved
creatures in the wild
each quest allows you to scavenge for
new gear and weapons
to wear or trade with the duplicitous
street vendors of humanity's new
settlements
or npcs in your own convoy
and then of course there's armor and
weapon mods which allow you to further
tweak your gear with modifiers that can
have a dramatic effect on how your
abilities play out in combat
layer in a full crafting system and the
staggering depth of outrider's loot
system begins to become evident you'll
need to be fully in tune with your gear
and abilities if you expect to survive
the game's post-campaign content
expeditions with a level threshold to
take part
expeditions is only for the hardiest of
outriders
pitting you against the most lethal
adversaries enoch has to offer
considered a suicide mission by most
your journey through the hellscape of
enoch is made possible
thanks to the outriders convoy a mobile
hub which moves through the world which
can be customized with body kits
paint jobs and oh yeah the skulls of
fallen enemies
trophies from battle aren't worth much
if they can't be shown off your convoy
will accompany you as you join a
friend's game and co-op
where your achievements can get the
eyeballs they deserve
this is all just the tip of the iceberg
as the outriders travel further beyond
humanity's reaches
the strange horrific truths of enoch
begin to reveal themselves
you